jet is due to the fact that I cannot say
or claim that it's a hundred percent
legit since it was sent to me and
therefore it could indeed be a legit
outline but it could also be nothing
more than a fanfiction however I say it
seems legit is due to fact that some
major events of this outline have been
confirmed by leaked photos and leaked
informations in case you haven't seen
part 1 of this episode I highly suggest
you to do so and then come back to watch
this video since first part included
some huge events such as search his
death okay the outline continues by
stating that the night King notices John
and his rayul it forces the night King
faces Aryan toward solving sad but
before he could burn them Danny and
you're gonna take the night King and
nazarian regalos so finally appears and
joins Danny and Jurgen in an epic fight
against the night king and the undead
Vissarion fire does no damage to this
area nor the night King in case you're
wondering how come fire does no damage
to be on when White's [ __ ] basically
corpses brought back to life by the
night King to act as his minions do burn
in fact fire alongside journalist is the
only way to kill a white well that's
because the night Kings dragon is not
white which was confirmed by the show
itself as the official season 7 script
stays the vissarion's the ice dragon it
also points out the desire has been
resurrected the same way Craster's sans
fur this means that Viserion just like
the White Walkers can only be killed by
dragon glass or by the Valyrian steel
where that being said let's back to the
outline it says that Sam s brain if he
could work into the night King dragon
branch wise but Kent
brain manages to work regal and burn big
among white saving Jon his railroad
forces from a huge horde Brandon Lance
Reagan John Snow allowing Jon to
mountain dry draco brandon works out of
regal allowing john to take full control
of Rey go with Sharia moons ryokan badly
Daenerys right Shogun out of fight
letting in the dragon pit Brennan very
sorry dragon pit to John starts burning
a huge amount of the army of the Dead
across the capital Melisandre shouts all
hail the warrior of fire not sanshiro
sister healing abilities during the
battle for King's Landing
Messiah also raises the debt the nat
king lands near to earth keep John
notices the Sun lands - let me stop
right there to point out that this
massive contraption King's Landing said
wearily Southland turns out to be legit
or not does confirm that at least one
dragon Malena King's Landing at some
point of the final season and with South
Thai needs to be believed it will not be
one but three dragons that will land at
the capital first Elena's regal work by
brain and later controlled by Jon Snow
Johnston riding regal the dragon named
after his father theory might finally
come true after the heartbreaking battle
beyond wall denier Sonjia students left
and seen
Sharath Shogunate would only fit for
John the other less link Targaryen to
write Ragle into battle at some point
beside regal Joker name is Arian will
land at King's Landing as well if some
of you been closely following how Game
of Thrones series has been created you'd
know that if characters have to mount a
drag on part of its spine has to be
physically recreated for the actors to
mount it which is exactly what this
massive contraption King's Landing set
is confirming the Dragons will indeed
land in the capital in the previous
episodes living already proclaim Jon
Snow a prince that was promised also
known as the Lord's Chosen the son of
fire and warrior flight which is coming
Sanjay hails to Jon Snow
it's said that Prince was promised he'll
defeat the darkness with a flaming sword
so perhaps Jon Schull is the prophesied
Savior and regal is his flaming sword
you'll soon find out if he's the one who
ends a long night and with an acting
landing near the Red Keep and so did
John the Alton continues by stating the
denier sees Jon Snow following the night
king inside the red keep with area near
a girl continue fighting about the red
keep
Tyrion proposes Daenerys to fly upon the
dragon one last time and burn down the
red keep killing tonight King and ending
the long night Tyrion says you know that
with the night King's death his entire
army dies along this is our best chance
this is our only chance
then he says the father of her children
their rightful king is inside red cape
as well then he continues by saying that
they must have faith in Jon Snow and
believe that he will end the long night
Joris says and what if you are wrong
your grace what if the night king is the
one who wins inside red keep what then
revealing to risk lives so follow us all
your people for Jon Snow
Brennan rubs their conversation and says
you can't kill Aegon Targaryen you must
not kill Jon Snow he's the prince that
was promised
kill him and were lost turn in this that
she must then he glances that red cape
and says I cannot do it jordan says John
is not a stark he's a Targaryen and he
once told me that fire cannot kill a
dragon
where's enraptured by saying fire killed
egg and the egg on the night John's
father was born Burnside sweet very
sense says the diner sighs so you walk
into a fire but John is not like you
he's not very resistant your fire but
his eyes brain turns to join continues
John scanned burnt when he grabbed the
fire lamp two kilobyte and save your
father search aura turned and says Danny
fire resistant or not you know that John
would want you to end it right there and
right now as he points to the red keep
what is the death of one man compared to
the deaths of hundreds of thousands
Tyrion continues Ragle still fights
Viserion about the red keep John snow
fights night King inside a red cape ray
goes fire
damage to vis Aryan is a shot of the
night king disarming and wounding chance
no didn't see a shot appearance fired
severely moaning regal in the next shot
we see tonight King raising his eyes
plate preparing to swing a final blow
and snow then we see regal ripping his
Aryan apart followed by a shot of just
not pulling out a Valyrian steel dagger
and stabbing the knight King through his
heart the shot and again such a stray
girl keep ripping the Zairian apart but
in the process just before with sharing
himself crumbles his Aryan breeds a
messy torrential blue fire in the red
keep burning down the red keep everyone
is in shock they lost the rightful king
aegon targaryen the army of the dead
dies the knight King has been killed
everyone is in shock especially Dani
Brandon Arya relieved that war has been
won but they've lost many people friends
and families they lost their King and
hero Jon Snow
the next shot shows us Danny Jorah
Tyrion grieve or Mario brainwaves bro
Ned murmuring Guinea and Theon walking
through the ruins of the red cape
towards the Great Hall after a few
minutes screen time of Long Walk the
group finally reaches the Great Hall
then is the first mentor it followed
closely by the others the throne room is
filled with snow destroyed with its row
being completely gone but Jon Snow is
alive sitting on the Iron Throne sirnas
blue fire did not harm Jon
everyone's surprised and in disbelief so
basically Jon ends the long night by him
killing the night king with a Valyrian
steel dagger Arya gave him when she
released him from sources dungeons Jon
surviving the Sirians blue fire might
have been for share of the division bran
head in the beginning of this episode
bran had visions of past and future
events and first fish included Danny
walking through the ruins of the red
keep entering the Great Hall and single
on throne covered by snow this would
surely be a turd the same or the similar
vision of the visions we had throughout
the entire show how has it for share of
Jon's driving and landing on the Iron
Throne
well it's particularly States and we
also see that the Iron Throne is covered
by snow Jon Snow back to the outline the
next scene takes place six years after
its spring and we're at King's Landing
John sits on the Iron Throne and has a
meeting with small folk King's Landing
faces growth and his final built after
the meeting is over Denise brings - John
they're twins were now six years old the
boys called Ned and the girl is called
Ella King Aegon and Queen Daenerys sit
on the throne but they do not ruled
Seven Kingdoms
they only ruled the crown lands we
learned that they decided that every
Kingdom will have its own ruler surely
after the Great War ended
let me stop right there to point out
that surprisingly now this part of the
outline has kind of been confirmed by
season 8 casting calls it says that
after the meeting is over Daenerys
brings to John their twins for now six
years
sold a few months ago there was a
casting role for twins aged 5 to 8 the
outline continues by stating the next
stronghold we see storms and we seeking
injury and queen aria they rule over the
Stormlands and they have a four year old
daughter named Sansa I also got a stop
right there to point out that this part
has also kind of be confirmed by season
8 leaks
it was revealed that Maisie Williams an
extra super chasers start from the scene
with a four year old child in Belfast
now keep in mind that this outline was
sent to me in August last year months
before filming or casting even started
back to the outline it says that we are
done at the Iron Islands they're ruled
over by King Theon Greyjoy we learned
that Theon has an heir and the son who
is around 12 years old the matter is the
captain's daughter
Theon met aboard Miriam here we learned
that upon your seniors deaths the theme
became king of the Iron Islands which
doesn't come as a huge surprise however
I'm sure most of you are wondering where
Stevens they are coming from and who is
the captain's daughter and when did they
meet on the ship well believe it or not
we've all witnessed this in earlier
seasons of the show in the second
episode of the second season aboard Myra
ham a ship taking him to Pike on Robb
Stark's orders
Theon paid visit to the captain's cabin
which he has taken for his own there he
made the captain's daughter who awaits
him in his bed naked after a bit of
small talk she up Steven and lays his
britches whereupon they had an intimate
relationship that apparently resulted
with the son
even though the show itself hasn't
provided any clue whether or not
feelings adventure with captain's
daughter resulted with the child in the
books Phil mentioned multiple times so
confident he is that he got the
captain's daughter pregnant the other
end and stayed there the next is
Highgarden which has now become a seat
of a ruler of the rich King Samuel Tarly
mrs. saime writing a book why little Sam
is being trained by a master-at-arms the
North is ruled by King bran Stark and
Queen Meera brain and mirrors father
having conversation in a Great Hall of
interval it seems like they'll finally
get to see how and read as the outline
states he's having a conversation with
brain also pay attention on a part that
says Sen writes a book the other uncle
teams by stating that we don't get to
see the remaining three strongholds out
of which the three remaining kingdoms
the westerland's the river lengths and
Dorner ruled but we get to know who
rules these start of a conversation
between Tyrion and Bronn this row riding
somewhere in the Riverlands we learn
that Tyrion is skinc Tyrion now ruling
over the westerland's from Casterly Rock
we also learned that the river Lancer
ruled by the Tally's bran complaints
have he fought during the entire war
against the dead and still has no big
castle of his own that's been promised
to him Tyrion gave him a minor castle
summer in the westerland's
says your sister killed the woman died
in that I could have married any rule
over Dorn
now Dorne is ruled over by elias and
princess of Dorne and continues with her
brother promised me a castle golden
hybrid beauty for a wife and he's died
and then they say that lanes hearse
always paid their debts he responds with
not the dead ones bran glances at Irina
Shayk his head turner says what I gave
you a castle hey you gave me a castle my
chambers the King's Landing were bigger
than this [ __ ] Brown responds
Tyrion smiles he once told me whatever
they promised me will pay me double bran
continues
Tyrion smiles again glances at Brandon
points on the twins the to bridge
castles Aaron says here not one but two
castles one can earn quite a bit of gold
by charging passing travelers and
merchants for the use of crossing in
there's free bride awaiting for you as
well this Scott Brown of guard for what
I care you can have that double to turn
continues and finishes with a Lannister
always pays his debts we also learned
that the remaining dragons Geoghan and
Rhaegar died of wounds shortly after the
battle for King's Landing in a shot
we're at Castle black we see Brienne the
new Lady Commander of the Nights Watch
in the first female in the history to be
a member in the Commander of the Nights
Watch their brain fills Jaime's entrance
in the book of brothers with his great
deeds
Brienne mentions James saving the city
of King's Landing and its population
from the met King Jimmy being savior
Winterfell I mentions his honorable
death dying while fulfilling his promise
protecting a stark child Brienne
finishes Jaime's entrance with the
greatest night to ever live so Jaime
Lannister knighted and named to the
Kingsguard in his 16th year at the sack
of King's Landing murdered his King
Aerys ii pardoned by Robert Baratheon
thereafter known as the Kingslayer it's
the duty of the Lord Commander to fill
those pages
and there's still room left in mine
someone forgot to write down all your
great deeds best of time is that for a
four-year-old night with one hand the
last scene takes place fifty years after
the year is 361 AC whistled Sam played
by George our Martin looking up from a
book as he finally reads the whole story
to little Sam's grandchildren Game of
Thrones stands with a child asking Sam
the name of a story Sam poses glances a
distance and says a Song of Ice and Fire
has this ending min Hinton tour
foreshadowed definitely with the most
prominent one being a cinema charge
misrepresents ever gathering books in
the state of the library their
conversation gave us a strong hint for
sensual being the narrator of Game of
Thrones histories have to do the
research if you won't be able to read
your histories you need a bit of style
I'm not writing a chronicle of the world
following the death of King Robert the
first so we can sit on the Shelf I'll
read what you don't like the title what
would you call it that possibly
something a bit more poetic epic fantasy
now also Song of Ice and Fire which was
later adapted in the HBO series Game of
Thrones most certainly does sound more
poetic this marks the biggest game that
Game of Thrones series might actually
end with the notes I'm looking up from a
book has he finally raised the whole
story even though there are plenty more
hints and clues going favor to this
theory which I already broke down in my
previous videos george RR martin was
already supposed to play a role in Game
of Thrones when he filmed a cameo
appearance seen unaired pilot episode of
Game of Thrones is a background pentoshi
merchant having in mind that he was
already supposed to appear in the series
George are more approaching all the same
in the last scene of game eternal series
most certainly doesn't seem to be out of
the realm of possibilities Irishman
during one interview Morris said that if
he was in the story he'd probably say no
tartly he's a great character George
Armour said Tyrion might be who I want
to be but Sam is probably closer to who
actually am the fat kid who likes to
read books and doesn't like to go up a
lot of stairs long story short it's been
hinted and foreshadow that Game of
Thrones would end up with the notes I'm
looking up from a book as he finishes
reading or writing all the events
however do I like the sending me
personally not really because they
follow this for events written in Sam's
book and we really believe in everything
that's been told to us artist arcs
really the good ones send
sir surely the villains of the story
what I want to say is that Sims look on
the events could be biased towards the
Starks and John snow and therefore
events might have not happen exactly as
we've been told which is why I'm not a
big fan of this ending but that's my
opinion this outlines so many major
deaths huge blood vests and as Kings
intention being finally revealed then
many epic battles the magic is
completely gone from the world with all
the deaths of the direwolves and the
Dragons what's better straight about it
is that the living has won against both
the night King and Cersei but with a
great cost the most of the living side
has died including some main characters
such as Jaime and Sansa and the ones who
survived loss their friends and families
now let me remind you that this Sultan
might or might not be the actual outline
of the final season it's very well
supported with leaked photos and other
information regarding season 8
especially because it was sent to me in
August of last year months before season
8 started filming which is the main
reason I decided to share it with you
however there's still a possibility that
this outline could be faked and all the
matches between this south